that's all i got the crab i only got
crab i got that's all i got
i'm a purebred entrepreneur for real for
real for real like documented
[Music]
do we have like some advices how to like
yes approaching is
using linkedin and instagram and twitter
and dming and just hand to hand combat
that's exactly the same way you grinded
for eight hours to drive here yeah every
day
but i want to make sure i set your
expectations the market is incredibly
challenging
every every every investor even for
people with a lot of leverage like me
investors are like this recession
valuations were too high so
you know
you have to be patient
i appreciate everybody fighting the rain
now i like how you said there's no rain
and the rain was like oh yeah mother
nature doesn't [ __ ] around she was like
oh yeah we want to stay safe so we have
to move inside and then we're going to
continue the time conversation okay
inside you know everything that you are
doing to bring women into web 3 and to
drive change and to embrace and endorse
tell us why that's so important to you i
just knew
what i was watching from january to may
in 20 which was
you know
highly curious web 3 blockchain
individuals were were the most active i
went first at my community which is
quite diverse by nature so that
immediately started to change the way
but then when i was watching the
projects themselves i would search
twitter and search discord and followed
and followed and waited for things that
were coming from black artists female
artists it was being educated and being
thoughtful that when you have a platform
you can have a variable difference on
the world
[Music]
i just want to thank you for the
captions that you taught your videos
accessibility and represent disabled
talent thank you for saying that having
captions is a huge i agree i agree
thank you thank you for saying that
[Music]
i'm really tall right now yeah between
two things yes the hungriness too
sexiest yes
and the gratitude
how do you make the balance between do
you feel it's anger do you feel it's
ambition
do you think you need people's
validation does it come from a place of
insecurity then it's not anger
it's hunger if i come up and i fall off
that's on me
if i fall not sell out that's weird
[Music]
what makes gary interesting
i think we learned a lot about that
today i would say you know haven't
thought about it it's like gary is 100
in everything he does you never see him
going through the motions man
you're just like fully committed even in
every conversation so you know that's
that's not right
you know what it is back to like
everybody like on some real human [ __ ]
with each other like
you're gonna be dead
forever right when you die
it will be dead forever unfortunately
the world works a lot if you eliminate
sleep
out of your life cycle and think about
how much of your entire life will be
work it's a high percentage to not fight
for that to be at least good [ __ ] solid
and and what are you thinking about if
you dislike it if you are genuinely not
happy waking up doing what you're doing
you literally need to stand up right now
call your boss and quit i'll lend you
some money you'll pay me back
and so to that point i'm all in because
i'm incredibly logical about this
it's a nanosecond
what you said about um essentially dying
that resonated with me so much and i
think that's the most fundamental but
also very simple truth yes what would
you say to people that because they're
not in those situations where it's
life-changing how can you help them like
create that sense of that sense of
urgency for them you know
everybody everybody clicks at different
moments you never know this is why i
produce so much content you never know
when the i've had people who've watched
me every day for six years and then this
piece of content was when they emailed
me and said this was it right so what i
say to them is
you'll never know when your moment is
but if you keep consuming the right
stuff yeah there is a trigger point it's
a process sometimes out of your control
sometimes an outside force does
something that moves your mentality or
your perspective in a different way that
triggers it right
my name is and uh well i'm a strangling
young actor yes i was in business before
and i watched your video like [ __ ]
monday all day and i wanted to start my
day being happy yeah i'm doing small
jobs like i'm working here i'm
contributing here
but i'm happy because you're chasing
your dreams i want to be an actor so now
i'm chasing my dreams and i'm watching
your videos like listening every day and
you have to understand you've already
won because even if you don't end up
becoming an actor well i will have to
try correct you you have to understand
that's a very big deal
when you're 60 70 80 90 the fact that
you won't have to ask yourself why
didn't i try you've already won
have a good time guys stay well
that's what i mean like before
i saw you happen towards the end i'm
like here we go
[Music]
welcome everyone thanks again gary
thanks steve thanks suzanne thank all of
you full of gratitude and love for this
beautiful evening in the south
[Applause]
you